what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and Aaron Alexander
are back for more of one piece we are
watching episode five today Aaron how
are you my friend I'm well I'm swell I'm
John Cena you can't even see me boy I
can't I cannot see you because I don't
see color damn straight
yes not gone
you feel me you're not robbing me are
you okay I'm sorry I'm going home
I'm sorry this is the last one Piece
episode he's canceled make a racist
remark
on my behalf
I've made so many racist remarks on your
behalf now it's a problem
[Laughter]
that's our intro leave a like
appreciate satire And subscribe and
click that notification like you're
notified when our reaction to the next
episode one piece is up here on this
channel oh as always full interesting
with your own copy one piece available
for supersection rejects over at our
patreon page thank you to all who have
joined certain people have pledged to
watch us watch One Piece with watching
us let's get to it
[Music]
thank you
just call that guy Grandpa
what a Twist the villain chasing him his
own grandfather maybe it's not his real
Grandpa he just had him call Grandpa
it's my first ship
had your time on this maybe he's not his
real Grandpa you're right
a little excessive I mean just talk to
the kid you are training begins today
[Music]
he was abusive
does Grandpa know that he's stretchy
that straw hat he's going after his
grandson oh I don't think so yeah no
load the cannon in the barrel light the
fuse and get the hell out of the way
oh no oh God
and you want to be captives
you had one job
he must know because if they can see him
then he must be able to see them lawyer
sales and submit to my authority
another year away yeah he knows yeah 100
but his grandpa have some gum gum whoa
Grandpa must
[Music]
okay damn damn
he saved his life out of all the
stretching Loop he's done that was
probably the most cartoony thing he's
done so far love it
let's go through a wide rail of emotions
right now like hot bad boy yeah he's
like angry and proud and he likes a
challenge yeah
[Music]
they could still unload their cannons
this show makes me want to watch the
anime this show makes me want to be a
thief
seal the season commit crimes who is
this duck
knife and fork interesting interesting
indeed you guys smell that there's
something on the breeze
smells like butter use your super
nostrils expand them really gotta get
out of this fog I know but I smell food
means that there's someone somewhere
cooking
there's a place nearby that's out of the
fog sail through the fog three degrees
back to Port add food to the equation
and suddenly he knows how to navigate
what is that
is that land at a restaurant
[Music]
oh fascinating it's like a port in the
middle of the ocean that's really cool
yeah what a cool world right
let's build this world more come on
there's like a theme park here to build
man oh totally let's get one piece land
come on do you have a reservation sir do
we need one we're very full today I
could put you on the waiting list
it's three weeks out jeez you wouldn't
want to turn away the future king of the
Pirates now would you and who is that
sir Monkey D Luffy
perhaps you've heard of him
we'll find a table yeah I knew it in
three weeks
can't they just eat at the bar
of course happy hour
right this way man
when he talks
I'd be happy to check your swords for
you sir just take them off bro
who are you get a move on if you're
slowing the line I'm gonna wait for the
source to cool hey you better keep it on
the menu whatever the hell that is boss
man ain't gonna like you I don't know
who this guy is but I already like him
what the hell is this I call it a true
blue film saute it's elephant tuna see
it asparagus in a sweet soy production I
cannot tell what this man's accent is
sounds French is but it's not like thick
though I'll freezes off I gotta sling
one more prime rib medium well I am
going to drop dead of boredoms you oh
[__] that's what we said insult to the
meat tonight
you are off the line now get out there
on white tables unbelievable he has
great hair and you treat him like that
shameful
you know the rules here we don't waste
food and there is no fight in aparati
after he apologizes for his Bad Manners
Over My Dead Body
oh okay footwork oh oh he's one of them
lanky anime characters with the legs
hands in Pocket also it's such a cool
really brought that to life it's so cool
it's got the Swagger yes apologies Madam
I didn't see you there would you care
for the pair of thief to stop something
sweet for someone sweet
nothing wrong with your eye just Blended
he's my favorite character
that was your favorite character he's my
favorite over this kanji yeah he's my
favorite character
we're making progress sir but the ship
is in need of repairs we've got to shore
up the yard reinforce the portion has
this guy done anything yet no but does
he have a sword he has a sword there's
like a samurai sword yeah he's wearing a
suit he must have a history with Zorro
in some way oh that would make sense New
York did I catch you in the middle of
something
about he canceled just killing some time
all right whoa what the sword
I have a request for you who's the
Quarry
oh
great wire work what an intro
doesn't sound like much of a challenge
he looks like a young Tom Cruise I see
Sasha Baron Cohen I can see that wow one
moment
I am
no I can't unsee it
he's my favorite character
it's time I ended this
oh he's dead 17 million huh prepared to
die why are you after me
you woke me from my nap
[Music]
[Laughter]
holy oh rap whoa damn
[Applause]
we're like 10 minutes in and we got an
introduction with three cool new
characters oh man this is awesome
[Music]
we got the death of one of the three
cool new characters
and mihawk
bring him alive
by any means necessary I can't eat
another bite but it's so good I feel you
man I have the same problem relatable to
the best cruise sailing on the sea and
do our Victory how are you gonna pay for
this what victory exactly against the
Marines
our very first battle line we crushed
him I don't know how many naval battles
you guys have been a part of who doesn't
at least but
[Laughter]
you didn't think to mention that your
grandfather was a marine and not just
any Marine a vice admiral no one would
have known I was there as opposed to
wrecking a base Commander's office
oh God
knows that thank you
you give them like a very generous tip I
guess but variety doesn't offer credit
as soon as I find a one piece I'm gonna
come back here pay this bill in full I
need a drink now you're talking how does
Zoro survive as an alcoholic you're
gonna pay off your debt washing dishes
wait
the next three episodes he's just
washing dishes
you can keep me out of the kitchen all
you like I'll never be a waiter well
that's fine by me because you sure as
they were never going to be a cook in my
restaurant oh tell them how good it
tastes you seriously don't think what
Luffy did is messed up what's advice
I can't get caught not when I'm so close
to what to what who are you talking to
if I wanted to secure passage to the
Konomi Islands who would I talk to
costume
six thousand I have buried it was just
regular random looking white man what's
going on here I'm a slip 22. be ready to
sail a dorm you're not going to vet this
guy at all to make sure that no I trust
you just showed up
what you said back at syrup Village oh
God I'm starting to think you might be
right about it of course I'm right you
ever hear of anyone called me Hawk
better with a blade than anyone in
living history one of the seven Warlords
at the Seas so what you're saying he's
gonna fight Zoro at one point why would
the more weddings need to work with
pirates to do the things they didn't
want tied back to them in exchange the
Warlords were given free reign so sorry
what you're learning about the Marines
you may know how to tie a knot but you
don't know [__] about how the world
works
dirty Marines you need to just go join
Luffy man get with the program join the
team have a change of heart in the
season finale the old man's a real piece
of work but you regret giving them the
IOU I don't really do regret sometimes
when I try to look ahead all I see is
back
that's a poignant line but that meal you
cook was incredible I should be running
this place but the old man's so stubborn
it'll never happen so that's your dream
Luffy always hones in on what people's
dreams are
this place
where
you can find ingredients from more
forces there's fish there that have
never been seen Rass seaweed spices
especially with this jazz music playing
that's my dream
if you want to cook you should cook
let them cook sorry I couldn't help
myself stand up to him
tell him what you want it's more
or something
I got Noir quality to this Sanji guy
yeah the coolness and the cigarettes
I'm so hungry
please okay please cook me a meal it's
the business we can't be giving handouts
to every down on his left pirate that
washes up so man is hungry I feed him
good man he's gonna cook a whole meal
it's not like a piece of bread the guys
the guy's starving it'll be yeah 30
minutes
like oh I need this guy yeah you should
join my crew sorry Joe boy I've already
got a job but you're not happy here
and we're gonna need a great cook if
we're gonna find the one piece
what did you say we were searching for
it too I was part of a mighty pirate
Armada oh the guy who just died hmm the
grand line was his undoing we lost 50
ships and 5 000 men damn off of one
sword forget you ever heard of the one
piece
settle for cleaning dishes oh hell yeah
look at him like he doesn't have a care
in the world what are you carrying
around that's so heavy I bet I know more
about you than you do about me yeah
right make it a drinking game
I get something about you
you drink hey it's not real alcohol
YouTube
I bet you grew up in a big city I grew
up in
a village barely available it just
a handful of houses in the center of a
tangerine Grove she's lying
she thinks she's lying
how do you know women lie hashtag
I'll bet you didn't have any friends as
a kid I had one friend
how long more than I had they're gonna
get plastered
we're gonna be really good friends by
the end of the night maybe she was
telling the truth yeah believe them ah
[__] believe her is it true you're
sending your cool mihawk after Luffy I
signed an oath to protect people to
treat everyone equally under the law
that's not the case
maybe I'm not meant to be a marine dude
don't do this on his ship
well out in the middle of the ocean
while he's eating is a criminal
come on I joined the Marines over 50
years ago I give him a simple ideals but
I had to adapt
the same set of laws do not apply to
everyone but that's not fair no it's not
life isn't fair
I could have been Fleet Admiral I know
but always turned down the promotion
because I'd have to do things their way
I'll be losing my freedom freedom is
everything
Marines are all that are standing
between order and Anarchy
I wonder if this guy really believes you
yeah
sure he does yeah a uniform it's
starting to fit you after all he did
take a stand when normally he wouldn't
and again
down goes the yard Marie's dead in the
water oh oh
you're the captain technically no I did
distract him so that Luffy was like the
official Captain dude
stop talking talk too damn much that's
your problem be my new best friend
oh God
he just looks like a bad guy
you're a Dracula mihawk or knows exactly
of course he does he's a sword fanatic
I've been following your career since I
was a child which is why it pains me to
inform you that tomorrow will be your
last day you're going to die all right
Zoro challenge you called it called it
to the death
let's go what if they kill off Zorro nah
lifelong dream it's the best you in
single combat
and become the greatest swordsman in the
world he has receive his goal then I'm
going to kill him dude tomorrow at dawn
and when I'm done with you pirate Hunter
I'll take your captain no no okay it's
probably gonna be something we're like
Zorro gets really injured and we think
he's dead but he's just gonna be healed
it's gonna be like this Marvel show
things or then do one of those things
where it's like a tie but something
breaks it up and they have to like have
the rematch later
no I think it's gonna get a really badly
you may have abandoned him from the line
but you can't stop him from cooking this
starving pirate washed up earlier
you did he cooked for him right here in
your kitchen he did what matter less to
him than making sure a hungry man got
fat
talk too much
tell your first mate he's going to get
himself tell your navigator to Bud Al
when you met me tied up on that cross
what did I say what makes you think I
want to play pirates with you
and you made a promise to someone a long
time ago to be the world's greatest
Swordsman
beat mihawk in a duel and take his title
even if you die in the process
you know I had enough character
development yeah you're not there yet
buddy yeah to go through like at least
three more arcs in story before you can
like achieve that you're the best I've
ever seen
but tell them you love him but I didn't
give a [__] because you're my friend you
idiot
you said it yourself
dude
[Music]
bro
you're my least favorite character
ah he's still my favorite oh my God are
they gonna fight this episode I thought
they were gonna fight next episode right
Sam happened to Netflix really
stretching their [__] out come on milk
it so I can complain about it later
what they are because he said yeah you
said it Dawn or like the next day I
think it's funny this episode okay cool
the choreography and the wire work is
gonna be crazy or very disappointing
or very brief
you have a choice to make
you have a choice stay with your people
you have to become a crew you have a
friend
nah dude yeah Zorro's gonna get his ass
kicked
it's so badass looking yeah he really is
let's begin
[Music]
oh
little blade yeah I don't hunt rabbits
with a cannon
[Laughter]
wow damn what a cocky line let's go
yeah he's gonna whoop his ass yeah
[__] damn
nice
hardly
God what is this strength ridiculous
does he have a fruit too from croaking
in a well
[__] I love this
[Music]
dude
one of us will become the world's
greatest swords to ever live
I just realized young Zoro kind of looks
like Ezra Miller
[Music]
that's not enough to kill him though I
powerful that blade is why don't you
retreat
oh he's gonna give him another chance
can't
well my dream will be lost forever
you're brave I'll give you that
he barely poked him so I'll do you the
honor of killing you with yorun
oh
wow that leaves an impression get that
one sword man put it in your mouth
yeah let's go
come on
what just happened so scared
[Music]
oh no
you broke his swords no he didn't cut
him did he no okay good wounds on the
back
our swordsman's greatest shame
magnificent
Jesus
no no no y'all Let Him Live he has to no
he has to avenge him he has to beat him
one day he's fight for his honor oh no
way no
they did not just dude
[Music]
no way he did not kill this guy no okay
no no it's gonna go down the Marvel
interest character path please oh he's a
scar to always remember him what's your
goal I'm going to become the king of the
Pirates it's a much more treacherous
path than even defeating me
um
that's what I'm going to do maybe you
Willard there this guy's a great
character yeah Roanoke Zora it's too
soon for you to die
grow strong and come find me yeah I told
you I told you you would get really
injured
said it's too soon for you to die if I
fail
to become the world's greatest swordsman
you'll be disappointed
right no could never fail me
never God I love these characters huh
what are you talking about that's right
the greatest Swordsman
it starts with healing I will never lose
again oh let's go
sorrow
sorrow episode 545 he's gonna fight him
I can't wait see
seven nine Netflix I know what you're
doing you want me to watch The Next
Episode I get it oh I get it I get it
you make me think he's dead no no no no
no no no in the next episode starts and
he's fun you're not gonna trick me yeah
you can't trick me I know what you're
doing silly games Netflix I know what
you're doing you think you're clever
what is hat guy's name
Luffy no no no the guy who looks like
Zorro I don't know mustache chin strap
God he's great he's so good he's great I
introduced two great characters there I
love the Sanji is his name Sanji Sanji
that's his name Sanji
um has such an Exquisite charm to him
such Elegance
um Debonair quality I would say great
word Debonair yes yeah I think he the
way he carries himself I love it and
then there's another guy who carries
himself with such regality as well the
this uh [__] um mustache trolling guy
with the coldness in his demeanor
excellent yeah I love it mustache swirl
man yeah pull out other words but I
can't pull out names
um it's okay this has been our strong
suit with this show but it's it's a lot
of names with a lot of characters yeah
but man what a setup I love how this
show just cuts when I'm so used to
Netflix sometimes delivering shows are
just like stretch out you know and and
and so I really thought like there's
there's a point in here where I'm like
I'm enjoying this
but is this gonna drag on like this
specifically this episode like are they
gonna really like just lounge around
this restaurant the whole time like I'm
liking getting to know these characters
and stuff but what is this episode
really going to be about is this going
to be a filler of some sort and and then
I like how it just kind of cuts through
the the [__] you know like we get
enough character build up we get enough
character set pieces we get uh Nami and
Zorro bonding with each other
establishing the Friendship of you know
not me having the choice of do I go solo
on this bathroom stick her with a friend
like getting that character beat but
then also you know like how you were
calling the second thick guy showed up I
was always gonna fight this guy and then
the show kind of just knows that and so
let's get that fight let's get that set
up there and then we get this really
impactful fight like no episode has been
a waste of time you know if this was the
anime it would have taken 15 episodes
yeah
he did it way too quick I remember him
for Live Action it's great I love it
the characters are great like it's a
great character and it still feels so
animated and vibrant yeah yeah I know it
feels animated and vibrant and the fact
that it's able to capture the the
tonality of an anime while also
not feeling like it's overdoing it or
feeling like it's it's out of place for
this for this show or for being in live
action everything in this in this
episode for me was incredible from the
fact that we got that fight in the
beginning and seeing Luffy confront his
grandfather from a distance to then him
discovering the restaurant and then
meetings uh meeting Sanji I I loved it
and then all the action here was
incredible this episode The Wire work
the the way that they did choreography
it's like
they found a way to make this heightened
thing super cool without like going like
over the top like like Michael Bay or
like
I don't know some like some stuff you
see in movies it's perfectly anime
without like Jumping the Shark and I
don't know if how to like explain that
in a way where it makes sense because
literally anime is like is heightened
action and heightened emotions but they
found a way to make it grounded and
accessible we get heightened at the same
time and found that perfect line to walk
to uh have the optimal amount of both of
them well what the show exceptionally
excels at too is introducing characters
and getting you
invested in them quickly quickly it's
surprising how quick they do it because
they did that with two characters this
time and they introduced oh my God I'm
so bad with names
the newest guy to the crew the newest
guy to the crew oh stop
[Music]
um they did that with they just they
just do that all around with everyone
and I I really do love how quickly I'm
like oh wow I love this character
already I love this character already
and they they're so distinguished as
well you know and the World building
again with this like
restaurant Pirate Bay where they can all
congregate didn't eat here like I think
that's really neat so everything about
this has been really Pleasant and I'm
also loving the journey that it's
putting Luffy on because the way what
this episode did in particular I thought
with Luffy and Zorro because Zorro is is
like the cool calm Jada guy that
whenever he's around you know he just
seems like you just feel like you're
safe when he's around like he's gonna
handle [__] right yeah yeah yeah and you
needed this element of stakes for him to
the point where when he gets he gets in
a fight he loses badly and quickly you
know so you need that for the character
and it it this is the most emotionality
we've seen propelled out of like pulled
out of him in that final moment to get
you really I was already invested in his
goal and invested in everything but to
give it a
to just have it be I want to be the
greatest swordsman is kind of broad
right but to make it a specific match
that he has to go up against makes it a
lot more personal and tangible for an
audience member to latch onto so I'm
glad they introduced this so early on
yeah and then for Luffy he's all about
inspiring people and then he made he he
gave the the words of encouragement to
Zorro as well
um saying like Okay this is your dream
you should go do it
and as Captain as leader I don't know
what the show is really going to do but
I imagine it's going to come with some
level of regret because clearly what
this show's has been doing is on top of
that is Luffy's so much of the person
who instills optimism and exudes
optimism and this episode was really
hinting at us even more so because yeah
they showed this pass through the group
with the pirate stuff and why they look
like there was a lot of rough upbringing
there
this experience of this grandpa is like
oh this is the first form of like this
guy was abused you know he had abuse in
his life right and that really hinted at
he's got a lot of darkness in him as
well yeah yeah and this is the first
episode that truly shined a light on
that
so I love that we're peeling back the
layers of the care so not only are we
getting new characters that seem really
cool we're also peeling back the layers
more of the characters we've already
been on board with yeah yeah yeah and I
think they they do it in a way where
it gives us more information about the
characters and endears us to them but
also endearing them to each other and
yeah it's like the the perfect folding
of those two things and yeah watching
them
kind of go through these these trials
and tribulations the fact that Zorro
lost his first fight of the series so
far only makes us root for him more
because you see the the courage and
tenacity he has and his desire to
succeed and yeah I think that they they
all have this this sort of quality about
them the fact that they all have these
these lifelong dreams or desires and you
know I feel like us as people we all
have those things that we want to
achieve and I think that's the access
point of this show is the fact that
these are dreamers going out dreamers
and loners coming out together to both
move towards a common goal true and
outside of it being anime or being like
a property that already exists I think
that's foundationally is something that
that resonates and can bring people
together whether they are anime fans or
not I think just watching this show and
and knowing that we are people that have
things that we want to achieve
as individuals and then seeing those
people's individuals come together not
only for a common goal but United as
what will eventually I assume will form
as a family a chosen family
um yeah really really resonates and it's
gonna destroys a lot of heart the show
is like oozing with heart and action and
character and Charisma and yeah I'm just
I'm loving it I'm loving the journey so
far Nick loving yeah it's great man it's
great stuff guys what'd you think about
this episode thank you so much for
everyone that's been on this journey
with us uh it's been a really fun
journey and I can't wait to see the next
three episodes uh we're gonna watch
episode six right now uh but before so
please subscribe leave a like uh check
us on patreon thank you to all who've
been joining but before we go listen to
the patron of the day shout out Michael
B Omni media ladies and gentlemen this
guy is one of the best reaction channels
out there he's also a great friend I
knew him as a great reaction channel
before became a great friend that's my
requirement before I become friends of
their reaction channels is going are
they a good reaction Channel all right
then I'll be your friend and Michael B
he's one of them and he's also covering
one piece right now I haven't watched
any of his videos for it yet I'm
assuming they're great based off his
tweets and how much enthusiasm he has
for the show but you know I just it's a
show that I'm we're also covered I don't
want to watch anyone else because
because they're my enemy they're my
competition at the moment now I still
want to be influenced and steal your
opinions like I normally do
but guys go so so so so so those who
though so
I don't see color show your support
to Michael B today
[Laughter]
Omni media that's omn one what a weird
spelling man Jesus you probably get
better views if you just spelled your
name properly oh hard is this time just
change the one who and I it's o m n is
it Nancy one media
that's a complicated asking the time man
it's complicated he found a following
with it I'm sure you know more because
there's strategic thing even more man
you should change it it's complicated
you say an omni anyway
it was taken what happens if I type in
Omni media not Omni one media but okay
if you pop up then there's no question
here
um media
yeah you still pop up here okay there's
no point in me saying anything all right
damn dude your [__] video got 50k
views on this video we just covered way
out of this
episode
[Laughter]
to this now
I was like anxiety first
don't watch his videos it's already
doing well
we have to win
[Music]